[Music]  things will happen to you  things that you cannot control  where I emotion will find you  when it does  what you do  will Define Who You Are  [Music]  Heroes reunite  I want to do something that matters  again  what the hell happened to my face  welcome back  I'm gonna compete with you buddy buddy  I'm worried you can predict the future I  worried people believe I can  my name is John Stewart welcome to the  problem with Jon Stewart we should put a  comma in that  the world wants to test us  to see if you can break us  we didn't beat you because he's better  he beats you because he's smarter  do you think we'll make it  not without my team  I think I can help you first thing I'm  going to do is completely unethical I'm  going to give you a hug I'm a hugger  remember to focus on the here and now  living in the moment it's a gift that's  why they call it the present y'all  foreign